-President Trump's ex-personal
fixer, Michael Cohen,
testified before Congress today.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
We say this a lot,
but today was truly
one of the most eventful days
of the Trump presidency.
It's not often you have one of
the president's
closest personal confidantes
testify before Congress about
their relationship.
And Republicans
were clearly freaking out
about Cohen's testimony
in advance.
One Republican Congressman,
Matt Gaetz,
tried to intimidate Cohen
on Twitter yesterday
by threatening to reveal
sensitive personal information.
-He tweeted this.
"Hey, Michael Cohen, do your
wife and father-in-law
know about your girlfriends?
Maybe tonight would be
a good time for that chat.
I wonder if she'll remain
faithful when you're in prison.
She's about to learn a lot."
-That's a congressman
saying that stuff!
Even if it was a Mafia thug,
the other Mafia thugs
would go, "Oh!
Leave the guy's wife
out of this!"
And I didn't think anyone
could outsleaze Donald Trump,
but you did it, my friend.
You were trying to intimidate
a witness on Twitter.
What's next?
Are you gonna Instagram
a photo of a brick
with a caption "about to throw
this through your window"?
[ Laughter ]
Now, all of this --
All of this was happening
while Trump was in Vietnam
for his summit
with North Korean
leader Kim Jong-Un.
In fact, at one point,
Trump was asked a question
about the Cohen hearing with Kim
sitting right next to him.
-Michael Cohen
and his testimony?
-Thank you.
-Look at Kim's face.
[ Laughter ]
I mean -- that is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Even he's like, "I'm so happy
I'm not Donald Trump right now!"
Now, Republicans are
obviously desperate
to dismiss Cohen's testimony
as a sideshow.
This morning Fox News host
Brian Kilmeade complained
that the other networks were
so obsessed with the hearing
because they have
countdown clocks.
-It's kind of amazing too --
another network
has a countdown clock,
not to Kim Jong-Un's dinner
and the negotiations
with world peace at stake,
but to
Michael Cohen's testimony.
-That's right.
Brian Kilmeade thinks it's dumb
to have a countdown clock.
So it must have come as a shock
when the show right after
"fox & Friends" immediately
put up a countdown clock.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe Brian Kilmeade doesn't
know what a clock looks like.
He thought those numbers
were the results of his IQ test.
Oh, no! Oh, it's going down!
[ Laughter ]
Once the Cohen hearing
got underway,
the GOP-ranking member
of the committee,
Jim Jordan,
tried to make a motion,
presumably to delay or interfere
with the hearing.
But he made the mistake
of yielding back his time first,
and the Democratic chairman
of the committee,
Elijah Cummings, wouldn't
let him have the time back.
-Mr. Chairman?
We are better than this.
I yield back.
-I wanted to note --
-Mr. Chairman, actually,
I have a motion.
-You yielded back.
-I have a motion.
-The gentleman
is not being recognized.
-I have a motion under
rule 2k6 of rule 11.
-You yielded back, sir.
-You yielded back.
-Amazing.
He tried to throw a wrench
into the hearing
but accidentally
yielded his time.
He forgot that the number-one
rule of Congress
is no takebacks.
And then it came time for Cohen
to speak himself.
Cohen wasted no time in going
after Trump personally
and directly
in his opening statement,
and he touched on so many
of the central questions
surrounding the President.
Everything from whether Trump
was aware of the e-mails
hacked during the campaign
to whether Trump had lied
about plans
to build a Trump Tower in Moscow
to whether Trump personally
reimbursed him
for the hush payment
to Stormy Daniels.
-He was a presidential candidate
who knew that Roger Stone
was talking with Julian Assange
about a WikiLeaks drop
on Democratic National
Committee e-mails.
Mr. Trump knew of
and directed the Trump Moscow
negotiations
throughout the campaign
and lied about it.
He asked me to pay off
an adult film star
with whom he had an affair
and to lie about it to his wife.
Which I did.
A lot of people have asked me
about whether Mr. Trump
knew about the release
of the hacked documents.
The Democratic National
Committee e-mails ahead of time.
And the answer is yes.
-Damn.
He just listed off a bunch
of alleged crimes
committed by the President
on national TV.
You know, it's so ironic.
Trump finally went to Vietnam,
and he's getting
killed back home.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
In fact --
In fact, Cohen even provided
a copy of a check
Trump personally signed
to pay off Stormy Daniels.
Look at that.
That is a check
the President wrote
while he was in office
to break election law
and cover up an affair,
and you can tell
because it was signed by
President Imama-mama-ma.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's signature looks like
he was trying to
draw a straight line
while riding
a roller coaster.
[ Laughter ]
Now, before today, prosecutors
did not technically identify
Trump as the person
who orchestrated
the hush-money scheme.
In court filings, prosecutors
referred to him
only as Individual One.
Although they did give us a clue
as to Individual One's identity.
On approximately June 16,
2015, Individual One began
an ultimately
successful campaign
for President
of the United States.
So everyone knew.
Everyone knew Individual One
was Trump.
And yet in his testimony,
Cohen still delivered it
like it was some big,
dramatic reveal.
-Last fall, I pled guilty
in federal court
to felonies for the benefit
of, at the direction of,
and in coordination
with Individual Number One.
And for the record,
Individual Number One
is President Donald J. Trump.
-Donald Trump?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Ay, dios mio!
[ Laughter ]
Cohen also provided
what he claimed
was an explanation for Trump's
behavior during the campaign.
He never expected
to be president.
He acted only in his own
personal interests,
and that's because
he saw the campaign
as an opportunity
to enrich himself.
-Donald Trump is a man
who ran for office
to make his brand great.
Not to make our country great.
He had no desire or intention
to lead this nation.
Only to market himself and
to build his wealth and power.
Mr. Trump would often say
this campaign was going to be
the greatest infomercial
in political history.
-It's true.
And like any product
you buy from an infomercial,
it turned out to be much
crappier than it looked on TV.
[ Applause ]
Trump --
if we're being honest --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Donald Trump is
the Slanket of presidents.
On TV you thought, "That's cool,
a blanket with sleeves."
and now, two years later,
it's stained, shrinking,
and filled with farts,
and you're like, "Get this thing
out of my house."
And Cohen wasn't just there
to testify about
the President's alleged crimes.
He also provided
information about everything
from Trump's long history
of racism to his net worth.
In fact, Cohen revealed
that even though Trump
waged a racist campaign
to get President Obama
to release his college records,
he made Cohen
threaten Trump schools
not to release his grades
and S.A.T. scores.
-I'm talking about a man
who declares himself brilliant,
but directed me to threaten
his high school,
his colleges
and the college board
to never release
his grades or S.A.T. scores.
-I shudder to imagine
what Trump's S.A.T. score was.
[ Laughter ]
"It had to be a perfect score.
I filled in every circle."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Cohen also --
[ Applause ]
Cohen also talked in depth
about the infamous Trump Tower
meeting with the Russians
in June 2016.
Again, Trump has claimed
he knew nothing
about that meeting, which was
organized by his son Don Jr.
Cohen said he suspected Trump
did know about the meeting,
based on something he saw
happen in Trump Tower.
-I remember being in a room
with Mr. Trump,
probably in early June of 2016
when something
peculiar happened.
Don Trump Jr.
came into the room and walked
behind his father's desk,
which in and of itself
was unusual.
People didn't just walk behind
Mr. Trump's desk to talk to him.
And I recall Don Jr.
leaning over to his father
and speaking in a low voice,
which I could clearly hear,
and saying,
"The meeting is all set."
And I remember Mr. Trump
saying, "Okay, good.
Let me know."
-He said it in a low voice
Cohen could clearly hear.
These guys are too dumb
to whisper.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, Dad,
I got an idea for a crime.
Whisper!
Hey, Dad!"
[ Laughter ]
"I got an idea for our crime!"
The standout line
from Cohen's account
of the Trump Tower meeting
is what came next.
Cohen said he was surprised
Trump would listen to Don Jr.
because of what Trump had said
about his son behind his back.
-What struck me as I look back
and thought about the exchange
between Don Jr.
and his father was first,
that Mr. Trump
had frequently told me
and others that his son Don Jr.
had the worst judgment
of anyone in the world.
[ Laughter ]
-Man.
You know it's bad when you get
dissed for being dumb by the guy
who threatened his college not
to release his S.A.T. scores.
"He's dumber than me,
and I'm dumb as a rock."
[ Laughter ]
Now, one of the most stunning
things about this hearing
was seeing the contrast between
the Republicans
and the Democrats on the panel.
Normally, when you are getting
ready for a big hearing
like this,
you prepare in advance,
you come up with a plan,
you coordinate your questions.
And some of the Democrats were
very focused and prosecutorial.
-Did the president call you
to coordinate
on public messaging
about the payments
to Miss Clifford in
or around February 2018?
-Yes.
-Was the president interested
in reducing his local
real-estate bills, tax bills?
-Yes.
-Is there any other wrongdoing
or illegal act
that you are aware
of regarding Donald Trump
that we haven't
yet discussed today?
-Yes.
-And now --
Now let's see how prepared
the Republicans were, like,
for example, Arizona Republican
Congressman Paul Gosar.
-There's no truth with you
whatsoever.
That's why -- That's important
to you, to look up here
and look at the old adage
that our moms taught us --
"liar, liar, pants on fire."
No one should ever listen to you
and to give you credibility.
It's sad.
It's sad that we have come --
in fact, I want to quote
the chairman's very words.
This is a real -- Hold on.
[ Laughter ]
-Gentleman's time has expired.
-Sad state.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-His time expired
while he was looking for it.
Really hurts
your big, dramatic ending
when you can't even find
the line you wanted to read.
It's like if JFK had gotten up
and said,
"Ask not what your country
can do for you -- ask --
hold on,
I have it here somewhere."
[ Laughter ]
"It was here just a minute ago.
Oh, I guess my time is up."
[ Laughter ]
Also, maybe when you were
preparing for this hearing,
you should have spent more time
getting your documents together
and less time printing up
a giant poster board
that said
"liar, liar, pants on fire."
I feel bad for the intern
who had to go to Kinkos
and print out a giant copy of
Michael Cohen's face.
Can you imagine what the
employees at Kinkos thought?
Oh, is this for some kind
of joke?
No, it's for Congress.
[ Laughter ]
This is a thing for Congress.
Again, you're supposed
to get together
and plan your questions.
Clearly, the Republicans
did not do that.
For example, here is Louisiana
Congressman Clay Higgins,
who tried to claim
Cohen was just doing this
to get a TV deal,
but ended up
embarrassing himself.
-One of my colleagues asked you
regarding the television deal,
you expressed wonderment
that your predicament
could possibly get you
on television.
It certainly got you
on television today,
has it not, sir?
-Sir, I was on television
representing Mr. Trump
going back into 2011.
-Well, I didn't know who you
were until today, really.
[ Laughter ]
-What?! What?!
You didn't know who Michael
Cohen was until today?
"You see, sir,
I don't own a TV.
I get all my news
from a gossipy alligator."
[ Laughter ]
Cohen is on the news
all the time.
there are babies out there whose
first words were Michael Cohen.
[ Laughter ]
Also, why are you dressed
like that?
Did you get confused
and think this was a wedding?
[ Laughter ]
You look like
one of the groomsmen.
Did you buy that vest
at Billy Bayou's Bridal Shop?
And then there was Jim Jordan,
the guy who accidentally yielded
his time before he was done.
Jordan tried to
impeach Cohen's character,
but for the most part
he just yelled all
the random buzz words you hear
Fox News pundits
screaming about all day.
-James Comey, director, fired.
Andy McCabe,
deputy director, fired.
Lied three times under oath
under investigation
right as we speak.
Jim Baker, FBI counsel,
demoted,
then left, currently
under investigation by
the U.S. Attorney's Office
in Connecticut.
Lisa Page, demoted,
then left.
Peter Strzok, deputy head
of counterintelligence, demoted,
then fired.
-That sounded like
a Fox News version
of "We Didn't Start the Fire."
[ Laughter ]
Lisa Page, Peter Strzok,
Benghazi, my shirt's untucked!
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's so -- Donald Trump
didn't start a fire!
[ Applause ]
It's so obvious that Democrats
got together
and came up with a plan
for how to question Cohen.
And Republicans got together
and were like,
"Okay, Jim, you yell at him.
Paul, you print out
the poster boards.
And Clay -- Clay,
we're counting on you.
You ready, Clay?"
"Oh, I'm more than ready.
Just one question.
Who is Michael Cohen?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm ready to dance!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today we witnessed something
truly rare and historic.
One of the President's
closest personal confidantes
detailing Trump's alleged crimes
and personal failings
for the entire world to see.
This hearing also showed that
Republicans are supporting Trump
despite the fact there is still
so much we don't know about him.
If Donald Trump himself
were called
to testify before Congress,
at least one Republican
would say...
-Well, I didn't know who you
were until today, really.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."